nous ce que nous proposons c'est une
méthode nouvelle au lieu de signer des
chèques sans provision ça c'est la
méthode macron utilisé à l'excès avant
les élections présidentielles qui ont
creusé ces déficits nous ce que nous
voulons c'est dire on inverse les choses
même si quelquefois ça le même coup nous
diminuons la fiscalité est ce qu'il est
normal que sur un litre d'essence 2
euros il y ait un euro 60 de taxes
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas supportable
donc ce que nous disons déjà nous
supprimons la taxe sur la taxe on paie
une tva sur la sur la taxe et nous nous
disons nous plafonnons pendant la
période de crise à 1 euro 50 le litre de
calan poisson